In Latvia, US Vice President Joe Biden assures presidents of the Baltic states...
...continued American commitment to the NATO treaty and Article Five.
In Turkey, the Supreme Military Council meets a second time...
...after the failed coup attempt in July to discuss the army's restructuring.
In Libya, government troops seize facilities in Sirte...
...that had been occupied by the Islamic State since last year.
In Pakistan, paramilitary forces raid the Karachi headquarters...
...of a powerful political party after its London-based leader incites supporters...
...to storm the office of a television channel.
And finally from Argentina,...
...farmers give away ten tons of apples and pears in Buenos Aires...
...to spotlight a crisis in the fruit-growing sector...
...and to demand help from the government.